okay can you all hear me is this thing
on
great thank you very much yeah first
slot after lunch lucky me
I hope y'all ate well my name is Matt
West and I'm here today to talk about
data science and I'm gonna try and cut
through some of the hype there's a lot
of hype around data science and we'll
try and give you a good idea of like
what data science is how it relates to
machine learning and to finally give you
some tips for getting started with your
own data science and machine learning
projects I wrote this talk not so long
ago when I started writing it I was like
very focused on trying to make it as
practical as possible but I soon
realized that like when you start
talking about data science you have to
include some theory so there will be
some theory in here as well
but I hope that like it's useful for
y'all my name is Mark West you can see
my Twitter handle down in the bottom
right hand corner and after the talk I'm
gonna put my slides out on SlideShare so
like you know if you look on the NDC
Oslo hashtag after the talk you'll find
my talk my slides there so who the devil
am i this is my first time speaking the
NDC I'm actually from the the the other
side of the water I'm well for many
years I've worked as a Java developer an
architect and the middle of last year I
was given the task of building up a data
science department at my company Bouvet
here in Oslo
so this talk comes from the perspective
of a computer scientist who has actually
learnt data science and in my spare time
I'm the leader of a Norwegian Java user
group called Java Bean and we arranged a
conference called Java zone that some of
you may have heard of anyway enough of
that let's go on with a talk my talk is
split up into three sections so if you
fall asleep in one of them and wake up
for the next one you'll you know get
your still get some benefits so I'm
gonna start off by talking about what
data science is and when define it I'm
going to talk about how it relates to
machine learning I'm gonna talk about
the roles you need and how you can get
started with your own data size projects
I'm then going to have a little bit of
theory I'm gonna go on to the machine
learning site I'm going to talk about
some different algorithms that you well
the most common algorithms use for
machine learning
I'm not going to talk about neuro
networks today a lot of people they
equate machine learning with newer
networks but like that's well machine
learning has a lot of other tools
available and I'm going to focus on some
of those and finally I'm going to run
through a practical example using some
open source data science tools so to
start off with what is data science were
to understand what they are Sciences you
have to understand why data size why is
there so much focus on data science
today and it's basically because we are
a date a German society and we're all
aware of that right I mean you read
about like Facebook and what is it
Cambridge analytic yeren swinging
elections and Twitter BOTS and all that
kind of nonsense you know the data is
out there and it's being used both for
evil and for good and our employers now
our customers they also want to be
data-driven they also want to get the
value out of data so it's no surprise
really there's so much hype around data
and data science and already in 2010
Harvard Business Review said that data
science will be the sexiest job of the
21st century and you know what's really
happened in the last few years is that
we have access to you know more storage
and more processing power than we've
ever had before and that's led to the
whole AI machine learning paradigm it's
been less academic and it's been made
available to us you know mere mortals so
basically Microsoft Amazon Google
they've all provided the sort of tools
that we can use to get easily start with
our own machine learning projects I
think this quote here or this this this
definition of data size is pretty good
and it's yeah it's from Wikipedia but
it's pretty good it says that data
science is an interdisciplinary field
with scientific methods processes and
systems to extract knowledge and insight
from data and if we drill down into this
we'll get a bit more insight into what
data science is firstly let us
interdisciplinary now I reckon that most
people in this room work with computer
science and like you know what we've
software engineering which is at the
boundary between domain knowledge and
computer science so in other words we
learn about our customers and there are
employees domains and we write codes
rules and whatever that
reflects that business knowledge using
our computer science skills but in if
you want to add data science to this you
need something else you need the math
and statistics side right I mean like
this is pretty obvious stuff it means
that like to work with daily sites you
have to either be a computer scientist
with good understanding of math and
statistics or a person with our kind of
natural science background say a
physicist who has a good knowledge of
computer science and don't forget a
domain knowledge a lot of people think
that like the data scientist is
basically a unicorn because it's
impossible to be an expert in all these
areas but I don't feel you need to be an
expert in these areas you can come from
one site for example computer size and
you can use time to build up your math
and statistics knowledge and and succeed
as a data scientist just like a
physicist can start a job as a data
scientist learn computing skills and do
a good job so we go back to our
definition of what beta site such this
it sorts about data sites been
scientific and data science its
scientific it's a scientific process is
driven by hypothesis and observation so
when you start a later science project
you need the hypothesis and the
hypothesis can be very specific or it
can be quite loose it could be can I
find out how much my house is worth
based on historical knowledge and what I
know about my house that could be a
hypothesis and what you have your
hypothesis you'd then need your dealer
that takes ages you gotta talk to all
the people around the day and get hold
of it then you have to get the data in
somewhere and you need to aggregate it
that takes time once you have the date
you need to start playing around with it
understand what's missing um is there
any insight you can get from the data is
there any parameters that that may be a
duplicated is there any extra parameters
that you can generate from the date you
have these first three steps are 80% in
my opinion are 80% at a data scientist
job you do all of this and then you can
start messing around with modeling and
like you build you know numbers that
before is about you know creating a
model you can use machine learning in
step number three of course you can to
understand the data but when you're
actually going to create a model to
prove your hypothesis our step number
four and that has to happen after you've
gather your date and you understand that
the next step off that of course is
interpreting the output your model the
resulting model or the resulting output
for the
might not be what you expect and you may
need to use some time to understand what
insights you're actually getting from
the model before you before you can
actually communicate to the stakeholders
and communication that requires other
skills that requires the storytelling
skills because if you're communicating
the stakeholders who don't know anything
about math and statistics and you're
trying to explain what your algorithm
just generated you're going to struggle
you need to find a way of communicating
to all kinds of people and of course you
end up the result now this looks like a
kind of waterfall step by step method of
course all of these steps are iterative
you know you can iterate between these
and there's lots of examples other
examples out there of data science
processes I know Microsoft there they're
team data science process you have the
older crisp data mining processes lots
of different ones out there but they all
have these basic things in common and
the other thing to remember with this
this process here it doesn't even talk
about putting your model in production
because data scientists often forget
about that and that's because later
scientists shouldn't really care about
putting models in production that
requires other roles so the data
scientist is there proving and
disproving hypothesis they're building
models they're kind of like they're
playing with algorithms and they're
communicating the results but you need
the data engineer if you're going to
build pipelines if you can a gavel a
date if you're going to put your model
into production and you're going to
maintain it not only that you're gonna
need somebody who helps you with the
storytelling you're gonna need somebody
who can visualize your data they say
every picture tells a thousand says a
thousand words right so like if you can
get somebody who's good at visualizing
your day you can get you can generate
insight from your data very very easily
and of course you need a process person
you can call that a project manager but
the important thing about that role is
that they need to be able to manage the
stakeholders expectations so your
stakeholders aren't you know give
stakeholders like well let's do machine
learning all right yeah we're gonna do
machine and it's gonna change the world
and then after eight weeks they haven't
got something because the data
scientists is still trying to gather all
the data
someone needs to maintain the division
and manage the stakeholder expectations
so the stakeholder in other words your
boss or your customer doesn't say oh you
know what this isn't working
data science is all about extracting
knowledge does that sound
you know familias IAM does it maybe kind
of sound a bit like bi it's data science
just the rebranding of business
intelligence and I think that's a really
fair question who thinks that bi is just
sorry that data size is just you know
old stuff in any wrapping I mean be free
to put you hand up I mean like you know
it's a fair thing there are some people
who believe this no and it's a fact I
personally don't agree with it but I say
that data science is perhaps more of an
evolution of business intelligence I
feel that the the differentiation
between a between business intelligence
and data science is becoming more fuzzy
over time and it is possible to have a
data warehouse in the data Lake sitting
side-by-side in your production
environment and they're both giving
value and I some of the areas where I
think that data size adds to business
intelligence and this is adapted from
from a great article I found on LinkedIn
I have to be honest about that but like
some of the areas that they a size
evolves from bi is like for example data
sources like bi tradition is about
structured data it's about data
warehouses daily basis you know schema
on right whereas data science allows you
to work with more unstructured data
you know log files tweets you know this
stuff is images audio files not only
that but like data science gives you
advanced technologies access to advanced
technology so so tradition to a bi you'd
be working with visualization and
statistics the machine learning gives
you you know more power you know you can
like basically use the Machine and the
algorithm to generate rolls rather than
you writing the rules to your codes that
you let the machine learning generate
the rules for you and goals as well what
do you get out of the IBI is about
steering the ship right the Titanic try
and avoid the iceberg
whereas data science adds the ability of
adding advanced functionality to your
systems self-driving cars chat BOTS you
name it automation facial recognition
and so on and so forth stuff that be I
never really thought of doing because
that was completely out of BIA scope
so won't talk about machine learning is
always talk about machine learning AI
deep learning what these will mean and
what how they relate to each other you
know in my world AI is just like a
general broad term that like refers to
everything that's about making computers
mimic humans so I love r2d2 you know
c-3po how 9,000 all of that is you know
in my in my head ai is not necessarily
what we're doing today what we're doing
is machine learning we're using
algorithms to help us predict based on
historical data and describe new day to
us that's machine learning and deep
learning is actually a part of that deep
learning is about building neural
networks that like have like more than
one hidden layer so neural networks
traditionally have an input layer and
output layer and possibly a layer in the
middle which is where you map from the
inputs the output and if you have like
lots of layers in your hidden layer
that's deep learning so it's basically a
neural network with lots of layers deep
learning again is I in my opinion is an
advanced topic and I won't be covering
that anymore today when we're focusing
on more general machine learning so
we're almost the beginning the end of
the first part of the talk so the key
takeaways is that data scientists
require math and statistics skills in
addition to the stuff that we do
everyday data slices hypothesis-driven
to undertake a data science project you
need a range of competences you don't
necessarily need before different people
one doing data science one doing day of
engineering you can have one person
there's more than one role but you need
to cover those competencies in your team
and in my opinion data sites can be seen
as an evolution of business intelligence
it brings more functionality and
technology to the table so we can go on
now to talk about some machine learning
algorithms and just to refresh machine
learning is about allowing your computer
so learn without your programming them
so traditionally you would give the
computer the rules you would say this I
want you to process things we're machine
and you give the the the algorithm you
give it data and then the algorithm
generates a model that has its own rules
and what we're talking about models now
rhythms just to reiterate so we have
training data that goes into an
algorithm and then the algorithm
produces a model there's a lot of people
that get confused you know so completely
this is actually the right terminology
when you're talking about
machine than the algorithms you're
talking about things that generate a
model and the other thing to remember
when you're creating models see machine
learning you need to be relatively
generalized so imagine that I want to
create a machine learning model that can
can look at a picture and tell me for
car is in the picture and imagine that
all my training data is based on these
high-performance sports cars okay so
everything's working I put my my model
into production and then the first
picture that comes is this or this or
this I mean they're all cars we see them
as cars but a machine any Matt algorithm
if it's not general enough it's going to
struggle because it's gonna think every
car looks like these here so it's very
important when you're creating your
machine learning models that you try to
make them general but not too general
and that's where this that's where the
challenge is it's all about basically
creating the model it's at appropiate
which has an acceptable error margin
which is generally enough but also pays
attention to the underlying patterns in
your training data you don't want
something that's under fitted that
ignores underlying patterns or something
that's over fitted that like you know is
is a oh if it is so much that it focuses
on modeling the training data perfectly
when it gets new day to its struggles in
fact this I found on Twitter this is a
great example of overfitting anybody who
knows you know machine learning in the
terminology you know here is somebody
has designed the bed based on how one
person sleeps us a training data right
so when anybody else tries to sleep on
that bed or if that person changes
position it doesn't work so that's a
great example of overfitting so machine
learning type says three basic types you
couldn't argue this backwards or
forwards but there are three basic types
that most people agree on you have
supervised learning which is about
prediction so we've supervised learning
you train the model based on historical
data and then you say you ask it to
infer new values based on what it's
learnt unsupervised learning is about
describing your data so you give your
data to the algorithm and the hour
them attempts describe your model based
on its features and finally you have
reinforcements then which is a sexy one
reinforcement learning is the model that
is constantly learning it's constantly
evolving the first two paradigms here
supervised and unsupervised learning
often result in static models that don't
change where a Sun reinforcement
learning is constantly learning so you
can imagine reinforcement learning is
like learning to juggle or to play chess
or something like that and again
reinforcement learning is advanced and
we're on the introduction side so we're
going to ignore that today and focus on
supervised and unsupervised learning and
three basic types of machine learning
that belonged long here you have
regression which is about predicting a
continuous value for example the value
of a house you have custom ocation which
is about saying okay is this an apple or
an orange and then on the unsupervised
side you have clustering which is about
finding groups in your data so I'm gonna
go through some examples of these and
just just in very very very quick
overview of these I'm not gonna go in
lots of detail I'm gonna start linear
regression the only regression is the
machine in the algorithm that a lot of
people say isn't machine learning
because it's so simple imagine here I
have some historical data which tells me
how much I can get for a house space
than this size this is great so
basically what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
create a model where I can predict the
price of a house based on its size and
that's simple first I just separate my
data into feature and label so the
feature is what I'm going to be putting
in and label is the examples are what I
want to get out of the model and if I
plot it my data looks pretty much like
this so you have like a knife this is
why I'm only using two dimensions
because it's easy to visualize so I have
like a nice little 2d plot of my floor
space and house prices so if I feed this
data into linear regression algorithm it
will generate one of these this is my
model it's a straight line because
linear regression it can be also called
a trendline and basically based on that
trendline I can make predictions so I
can say okay based on the trendline if I
have a house which is around about 5,000
square meters I can expect to get
approximately 1.5 million for it
and that's it that's the near aggression
it's as simple as that of course its
simplicity makes it very weak in some
ways because like for example here we
have an example of a deviation this is a
data point from my training my training
data which is a long way away from that
trend line which indicates that perhaps
my model isn't good enough unless admit
you know let's admit it I mean like my
model is based on the size of a house it
doesn't take a count to where the house
is how many rooms it has how many
bedrooms it has what stay is in right so
there's lots of other features here that
really should be in the model so a
deviation you know indicates my model is
quite weak it also though could be an
outlier an outlier isn't anomaly in your
data could be an error missing data
something like that and allies are
dangerous because when your model tries
to draw a line through all of these
spots that is as close to all the spots
as possible cuz that's how the linear
regression works it tries to draw a line
that there is as close as possible to
all these different data points if you
have an outlier it's gonna drag your
trend line away from where it should be
so that's the weakness with linear
regression so very very quickly linear
regression is easy to understand it's
transparent but outliers can skew the
trend line and of course it's a linear
regression so it doesn't work well with
nonlinear relationships but you can find
other alternatives of regression that
work better with nonlinear relationships
I'm gonna go into classification the
support vector machines support vector
issues are relatively not relatively but
like I'm though about 15 20 years old so
they're relatively new compared to some
of the other algorithms that are out
there and they took me quite a while to
get my head around but basically support
vector machines are about classifying
your data and here I have some training
data where I have all my data points and
they're already classified into or
they've already got their own classes
ones green ones blue and what I would do
is I would normally feed this into an
algorithm and the algorithm would tell
me ok it would give me a model it could
predict the class of new data so how
support vector machines does works as
it's basic and define in line between
these classes and visually it's very
easy to draw a line between these
classes right you can draw it here you
could also draw it here you could draw
it here as well and that's the question
where should your line be to get the
best results from new data when you try
and test your model a new day so where
should the line be
and support vector machines have a
opinionated solution to this what they
do is they will supply they will find
the data points in each class that
closest the data points in the opposite
side these are the support vectors and
it will then use these support vectors
to find an optimal boundary between your
classes so any from now on and the like
data points that fall on this side of
the line will be blue and any data
points the other side will be green and
that's great but there's a problem
what if there's outliers in the boundary
they could actually force your model to
be wrong right they could actually force
the line the optical bound you eads be
in the wrong place or what if you have
you know somewhere like this where the
line between the dey're isn't
necessarily so easy to draw now the
thing is very very important that you
could draw a line between these you know
because the support vector machines
support nonlinear lines but the problem
is is that like if these are outliers on
the edge you're going that where model
isn't very good so basically what
support vector machines do is they they
allow you to define a buffer zone you
can make it as big or as small as you
want and here I've just generated the
small buffer zone and any training data
in that buffer zone is ignored so we
only pay attention to the training data
outside the buffer zone which allows us
to define lots of a boundary which
ignores outliers and noise in our
training set so support vector machines
are very resistant to outliers and work
well with linear and linear boundaries
and they're good with high feature sets
with large feature sets high dimensions
but there can be a bit tricky to tune
and they do work best with binary
classification where you're basically
saying true or false
decision trees I like because they
really fit into my understanding of the
world as a computer programmer because
decision trees are basically a flowchart
right so imagine here I have some test a
test example and this test is always a
very normal decision tree example and
sometimes people use it to decide
whether to play golf or sometimes they
use it to decide we're going to play
tennis I use it to decide willing to
play golf or not so basically based on
the features the outlook the temperature
the humidity and the winds then I decide
whether to play golf and I then can
separate my data into features and
labels if I feed that into a decision
tree algorithm I will get something that
can be visualized like this
it's not a slide down tree and at the
top I have my roots and I have my
branches and finally I have my leaves
and it's just a flowchart but how does
the decision tree algorithm built this
flow charts how does it decide which
feature to prioritize first wait does it
doesn't it called recursive partitioning
and the algorithm looks at your data and
tries to find the best feature that
splits your data into two homogenous
groups and the feature that finds first
its best splitting the data is the
outlook and then it goes on to the next
leaf and so on and so forth until it
reaches some kind of stopping criteria
either in models everything and like all
the data points at the bottom at the
same values or if you reach another
threshold like how deep do you want your
tree to be because the deeper your tree
is the more prone it is to overfitting
so decision trees are very easy to
understand the flexible can use a
regression and classification there
isn't two outliers and they handle
nonlinear boundaries but they are
susceptible to overfitting that means
that like basically your model will be
very effective will be affected on where
the algorithm decides to slice your data
and if you have some noise in in your in
your training data which affects where
the data is sliced you can end up with
anomalous results the final algorithm I
want to talk about very quickly is
k-means clustering which is actually my
favorite because it's so nice to
visualize and k-means clustering is
about describing your day or group in
your data without doing the training so
this is describing not predicting and I
have a some test data which I've
generated and basically came is
clustering is all about grouping this
data into groups K is basically the
amount of clusters the algorithm will
try and find K needs to be large enough
to get meaningful patterns but not
certain you know so large that it's
meaningless so there's a hundred-fifty
data points here if I had 100 clusters
that would be kind of meaningless
if I had one cluster that would also be
meaningless right so you need to find
the right value for K and how do you
calculate that well there's different
ways of doing it but an easy way of
doing it is by calculating the K V Lee
cave value using screen plots
and this is a scree plot basically they
are just shown you and what the scree
plot about how you generate a scree plot
you run k-means with lots of different
cluster sizes and you plot the basis you
plot the amount of clusters against the
summer squared error I don't want to go
into too much detail about this but the
summer square that squared error is the
same as if you if you fire a bow and
arrow a target if you hit it right in
the middle that's like being in the
center of the cluster and then your your
error will be zero but if you are a
little way away from the center of the
target then that's an error so basically
what the summer squared error is about
is looking at the cluster and it's
saying how far is each data point away
from the center the cluster the more
clusters you have the lower your Summa
squared error and like basically what
you're doing with the scree plot is
you're trying to find the elbow of the
plot anybody want to guess where the
elbow is yeah was that sorry you three I
thought I thought you sorted so I
thought the guy behind you raised his
hand sorry they said yeah you're right
it's at year three the the error at the
elbow is at three so I take three and
then I take it back and I run my
algorithm saying I want you to find
three clusters the first thing algorithm
does is it finds three sensors and it
just places them wherever it wants to
these three centers are placed
completely randomly so next thing well
the algorithm will do it will allocate
each data points to a cluster based on
how far that data point is away is away
from the center of that cluster but then
it's now it's done that now the sensors
are no longer at the center of their
cluster so we have to move the center's
to the center of the cluster and then we
have to update all the data points again
so they belong to the cluster that
they're closest to and so on and so
forth and after like six iterations you
end up with a stable model now we have
three clusters and that's basically how
K means clustering works now k-means
clustering has its it's very fast it's
very easy to do but it really focuses on
spherical clusters because you're
calculating the euclidean distance
between a data point and the central
cluster so it's going to generate
circular clusters and it's not very it
doesn't like it doesn't like it when you
have a data point that can be assigned
to two clusters for example
Kenny's clustering is powerful and quick
but if you have clusters that aren't
spherical maybe need to look at a
different type of algorithm so that
that's basically it for the machine
learning algorithms but like this
there's machine learning needs data
science skills because we can use a
product it's very easy to use a product
these days and just like like Azure
machine learning or whatever and you're
just pumping your data and then you'll
get like you know success out I mean is
it that easy I would argue it isn't I
would say I would argue that you need
data science skills so that's that's
what he's saying yes he's saying yes you
need data science skills just to convey
like below and basically you need data
science skills because you need to kind
of be able to select and work with the
data going in you need to like do proper
variable selection you to engineer your
features you need to kind of like impute
missing dates that kind of thing
you need to understand how the
algorithms work you need to know which
one to use and how to tune it and you
also needs to insert how to interpret
evaluate and communicate the results
from your model so yes you do need data
science skills to work this kind of
stuff so key takeaways are there's three
types of machine learning you need to
join that you create models that are
generic enough not too generic but
generic enough so you get that that got
that sweet spot between overfitting
under thing and that often means that
you just have to generate the model lots
of times and see where you get the best
results with new data machine then the
algorithms are just source if you don't
know how to use them they're not gonna
work you're not gonna get good results
you need to understand how they're
working and finally you need data
science skills it's a work machine
learning so now we're gonna go over to
the practical part of the talk where I'm
going to basically show you just some
stuff that I've done and this is this is
very simple low-level stuff basically
I'm going to be focusing on the hello
world of machine learning which anybody
is plagued machine learning is probably
played with the Titanic data set and
basically you have a data set where you
which you use to build a model for
predicting survivability of the Titanic
and in my case I'm going to go with a
simple hypothesis that I can predict
Titanic's live at survivor
let's say based on age gender and ticket
class now the reason I chose Titanic
today was because we all know Titanic we
thought well probably about not
everybody would admit to having seen the
film but I'm sure that most of you have
and those that haven't have read about
it or heard about it from pop culture so
I don't have to use lots of time to
explain to the main the reason I'm
choosing age gender in ticket class well
aging gender is like women and children
first we've all heard that right and the
other thing is ticket class because you
know it was very clear from watching the
film Titanic that the first-class
passengers were treated a lot better
than poor old Leonardo DiCaprio right so
that's why when they use these three
values to try and predict survivability
this is what the Titanic dataset looks
like without going too much into detail
on every value but you have a unique ID
for the passenger survival when lay
survived or not the class which is one
two or three number one is first class
number three is third class the gender
the age the amount of siblings and
spouses on board the amount the parents
and children on board the ticket number
the fare the cabin number the port of
embarkation which is either Queenstown
Cherbourg or Southampton and finally the
passenger name which includes your honor
if ik the honorific is mister missus
lady and so on and so forth so I'm going
to be focusing on predicting this value
based on these ones it's also gonna be
using only using scikit-learn
scikit-learn is a Python distribution
which includes other Python libraries
which basically allow you to do machine
learning so scikit-learn itself has
implementations of different machine
learning algorithms and it also packages
up some other Python libraries such as
numpy which is good for doing maths
pandas which is good for data sets and
matplotlib which is good for visualizing
your data I'm going to be showing you
the code in the Jupiter notebook Jupiter
notebook is a very handy tool where you
can basically both write code and run
its but also write notes so it's very
good if you want to share the results of
your data science project with others
and if you want to use these in play
with scikit-learn and Jupiter rather
than downloading them separately
definitely recommend downloading
anaconda that's a distribution we've
like lots of machine learning and data
science tools built-ins such as I think
you have like I think actually we got a
visual studio version in there as well
so let's switch over to my Jupiter
notebook
I might have to mess a little bit around
the resolution look at that I have to
look at mess around with the resolution
so you can actually see what's going on
here but let's see if we can just zoom
in a little bit yeah okay so the first
thing I do is I've got my dataset in in
the CSV file so I'm going to import my
day to using something called pandas and
this is what the data looks like when
I've got it in pandas gives me all my
data my CSV data in a nice little data
frame and we can already see there's
some interesting stuff here we can see
the honorific for example is always at
position number 2 in the names if you
tokenize your honorific you will
definitely be able to pick outs so if
you tokenize the name you'll be able to
pick out the honorific we also know it's
that male and female is sets two strings
and age has some missing values you have
a null value here and a null value here
so what pandas does it gives us the
ability to actually generate reports
based on our data so if we zoom in to
this here we can see that we actually
get some insight into the numeric parts
of our day or we can see that we have
891 values 891 rows no data set we can
see that age is missing
177 values and that's an issue because
we want to impute well you want to
calculate survivability based PI and age
but we'll come to that in a moment
we can also see from the survival mean
value that around about 38 percent of
people in my dataset survived the
Titanic disaster the reason for that is
the reason I can tell that is because
survived is set to 1 if they survived
and 0 if they died and this is the mean
value across a dataset
so what yeah what we need to do is
because age is a predictor of
survivability we now if we need to do
something with the missing age values
and we have two two choices here one is
to just delete all the rows we vernal
age and just say that it's not important
for us but then we're losing like a
quarter our dataset which also has
information on gender and class so
that's probably a silly thing to do so I
would argue that like instead of just
deleting them we should maybe try and
impute those missing age values and
there's lots of different ways of doing
that belonging to this site I'm going to
try and do it using the name
I mentioned already that we have the
honorifics another name so we're a bit
of simple Python magic I can actually
extract the the honorific and I actually
create a new column which is called
honorific which just contains that and
now I have that it's very easy for me to
get an overview of how many honorifics I
have I just zoom in there so yeah we can
see that most of the people in my
dataset amidst us and they're quite a
few of them mrs. and Miss and master and
yeah but then if we go down here we have
like John Kier I think that's a
Netherlands how do you say that Dutch
sorry
I think that's Det that that's Dutch and
then we have mum Moselle and we ha MS
the countess and ladies so and so and so
forth so it's a bit you know okay this
is interesting but maybe we should try
and normalize these values a little bit
so that's what I'm gonna do next I'm
going to create a nice little map which
allows me to map the existing honorifics
to more generic ones so the ones on the
left hand side of the existing ones the
ones on the right are the new ones and I
found out by doing a bit of research
that John Kier is like a sir I found out
also that what was it yeah
mama's L is like Miss Madame is like
missus and so on and so forth so what
like there was I in that we've less
honorifics and then what I can do is
using a boxplot I can visualize the age
distribution for each of the new
honorifics I've generated so I'm not
gonna go into detail what a boxplot is
but like what's great about this is for
each honorific I can see in this green
line here I can see the median age for
each honorific and then I can use that
to fill in the missing age values
and that's what I do here let me just
zoom out hang up the phone I just use a
bit of playful magic which basically
does that I think I need to see there we
go but I'm not going to go through the
code because that's not interesting the
next thing I need to do is I need to fix
the sex categorical variable because
it's a string so will I do is I'll
replace the string with a 0 or 1 if it's
male I replace the stream with 0 and if
it's 1 I place it with so if it's female
I replace it with 1 simple and then the
next thing I do is I've got all these
features now in my data set that I'm not
going to use anymore I don't really care
so I've got my I've got my survivor I've
got my class I've got my sex nage that's
enough I don't need all the other stuff
so I'm just going to throw it out the
reason I'm going to throw it out is
because I don't want to introduce any of
these extra values into my model by
accident so just makes it easier for me
to work with right so does the data we
have now after having you know mr. a
little bit does it reflect our
hypothesis well that's the cut
survivability related to class or zoom
in here so I've generated a nice little
bar chart based on the class one two and
three
first class is best second class is
second best in third classes is a
jackdaw snored Leo DiCaprio and we can
see look like you know those that are um
that have the blue values those the ones
that died and the ones that are brown on
this screen at least other ones that
survived so we could see here that if
you're in third class you know you you
you the odds were against you right if
you're in third cluster a lot more
people died in third class in my dataset
at least than survived and in first
class you can see that like more people
survived and died and in second class
it's approximately the same so it kind
of gives an indication that the idea
that survivability relate to classes is
a fair one
what about gender well this is also
interesting here again we see look like
remember that gender null is is male and
gender one is female so here we can see
that if you agenda nope in other words
male the chance of you who are surviving
will have that great
if you were female the chances of
surviving were you know substantially
better according to my data set and the
final thing is age and this is a bit
different it's a bit more interesting
because what we're looking at here is a
distribution of data and basically where
this these two first peaks are above
what a zero those are the people who
died and the one that and the the peak
above one of those people who survived
now what we can see is a distribution
for adults in other words people over 15
years more people died then survives but
the distribution for kids yeah more
people survived and died but not that
many more which is actually over you
know for me was actually surprising cuz
I thought that I was going to say that
like loads of kids survived and loads of
adults died but when you start thinking
about if you start looking at a
distribution of children over classes
there was a lot of kids in third class
and if their parents died then they
probably weren't able to look after
themselves so now they knew I've got my
data I feel quite comfortable don't like
I'm going to get good results right so
I'm gonna feed it into my ship machine
machine learning algorithm and the first
thing I do is I'm gonna split my data
into features and labels so the features
or there's definitely something going on
with my resolution here just bear with
me a second while I try and make that a
bit nicer I want to make it readable for
you guys right so let me just open it up
again
Dropbox there we go and then just there
and then there you just open up again
and make it a bit more let's see if we
can get better results this time just
run through everything sorry about this
this is like previously in my talk
alright okay there we go so what we're
doing yet so first thing we do is we've
we split our dataset into features and
labels so the features look what what
we're gonna use to predict and the
labels is the values we want to get out
and then we're gonna split our data into
testing and training sets and this is
very important when you're building a
machine any model you have you cannot
test your date it was the same you can't
test your model with a say
they are they used to train there
because then all you're doing is your
ask the model do you remember this
you're not checking if your model is
generalizing so you always split your
dataset into training and testing sets
and well there is I'm saying 25% of my
data will be used for testing and 75%
will be used for training and how I
select how I separate the training the
testing data is randomly so I don't end
up like you know pulling out 25% of rows
that are all after each other because
that can also be a bit cheeky so like
it's basically picking out 25% of random
rows to to comprise the testing set so
now I let my decision tree learn based
what I do is I feed my decision tree the
the features the training features in
the training labels I don't change any
hyper parameters all these values up
here these are high parameters these are
like defaults because I haven't set them
and then what I end up is we have a
model that says okay
it gives me around about 75% accuracy
based on me comparing my my predictions
from the model based against real data
so around about 75 percent accuracy it's
not too bad it's not too bad and if I
look at a confusion matrix that gives me
more insight but this confusion matrix
the vanilla commute confusion matrix is
actually very confusing so that's why
it's called a confusion matrix so I like
to actually generate a prettier one
which is like down here if I can just
zoom into it and then you can possibly
look at it a bit better there we go so
in this confusion matrix what it does is
like the true labels the ones are the
ones that like vertical and the force
label is a horizontal and what we can
see if I just zoom into that scroll down
a little bit ah they all just being
cheeky hey guys there we go so what you
see is that lot I correctly predicted
hundred and fourteen people died and I
correctly predicted 53 people who
survived from my testing set but I got
20 of those who survived wrong and 36
have those survived of those 36 of those
who died wrong
so basically it gives us an idea of like
where we're going wrong here so what I'm
going to try and do
is it look at the tree this is the tree
that I've actually generate the decision
tree that were generated and it's a
behemoth
it's a massive decision tree and that's
just for three features right that kind
of indicates to me that maybe I've over
fitted my model because I haven't set
any maximum depth to my tree so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to run the
model again and there tweak my pipe ramp
doesn't sound little run my model with
just three let it generate just three
layers of decision tree and when I do
that immediately I get a better result
I get 80% so I've actually got five
percent better score just by making my
model more generic unless like over
fitted and if I look at the confusion
matrix I can see then now I've actually
managed to predict one hundred and
sixteen died correctly instead of
hundred fourteen and the biggest change
is the amount I predicted survived I
actually with the first version the
model ie got fifty three right but now I
get sixty two right and if we visualize
the tree which is now limited to three
layers it's a bit easier the kind of
light follow so basically what I want
you to take away from this is that like
by tweaking your high parameters and
understanding how your tree or how your
machining algorithm works you can
actually get better results very quickly
I also want you to understand that
feature engineering in other words
playing with your data and make you know
getting it ready to put into your model
is actually the majority of the work
you'll be doing as a data scientist
right so yeah I would say scikit-learn
than jupiter notebooks very good because
they're an easy way to get start with
datacite you don't need to sign up for
anything you can just download them for
free as part of the Anaconda package and
you know well I would definitely
recommend if you want to start playing
around a data Sciences get download
these and they put Kaggle because
Calculon got lots of datasets including
the Titanic datasets and lots of trip
tips and tricks for getting started I
would say feature engineering as I
mentioned is a vital skill fall day at
scientists and domain on they domain
knowledge is key because if we didn't
know about Titanic we wouldn't mean
that'll follow this example because it
would have taken me at least half an
hour to explain not what the Titanic was
what happened you know all the stuff we
know from pop culture I would've had to
explain so domain knowledge is very
important also don't you know always
remember to split your data into tests
and training sets and remember that
tweaking your machine and the algorithm
can give you better results so basically
that's it for the talk today I'll be
putting the slides out on my my my
Twitter right after the talk I'll just
put them on to SlideShare first and then
I'll put them up on the the NDC ozlowe a
hashtag and other than that thank you
very much for listening
[Applause]